fais pas je crois qu'il ya un tout petit
ennui technique vous voyez nous nous
sommes prêts je vous demande quelques
instants de patience
j'en profite pour dire bonjour alain
bonjour patrick alleyn panard via une
panne la plus grosse panne mais est ce
que est ce que ça fait quelque chose
qu'il ait une panne ou une eau non c'est
pas grave alors c'est pas grave alors
rassurez vous prenez un tout petit peu
de patience et je crois que ça va ça va
se réparer très calmement
wallach
voilà
bon bon bah voilà
nous sommes dans le coin peinture avec
alain alain tu peut d'ailleurs faire ce
que tu veux si si tu te décides de faire
un tableau
elle veut te par les cheveux non mais
moi je regarde ce qu'ils ont fait la cm
seulement extraordinaire qu'est ce qui a
fait ce petit bonhomme qui est jaune
qu'on regarde juste en face de nous avec
un chapeau marron c'est toi comment tu
t'appelles marjorie voilà je lui demande
son prénom elle s'appelle margerie elle
aime bien dessinés qu'elle a battue
alors tu l'as fait en combien de temps à
peu près longtemps n'ont pas longtemps
tu aime dessiner
oui elle aime dessiner margerie alors on
va de ce côté là mais c'est vraiment les
peintres les peintres professionnels
comment t'appelles-tu sabine et elle est
mignonne comme tout qu'est ce que vous
en pensez mon cher alain qu'est ce que
c'est que tu as fais là c'est une maison
avec une horloge c'est une mairie c'est
quoi ça écoutez on va laisser on va
laisser voir prendre les canards les
caméras de marion sarraut prendre cette
belle mairie regardez voilà vous savez à
quoi sert une mairie eh bien il ya des
tas de papiers administratifs que l'on
peut y trouver et puis aussi on se marie
dans une mairie tu le savais vient près
de moi dis moi quel âge as-tu 12 ans
comment t'appelles-tu franck alors le
mariage c'est pour bientôt
non parce que à la mairie le jour où tu
voudras te marier
tu passeras devant monsieur le maire
voilà monsieur le maire mais ils savent
tous sans problème écoutez je crois que
tout va très bien de toute façon tout a
toujours été très bien et je vous
propose de partir en musique avec ce
club dix quinze ans que j'ouvre avec
alain souchon
rebonjour si vous venez le feuilleton
alors 15 ans mais pas tout à fait ouvert
la porte et quand même entrouverte et
voici le feuilleton l'autobus à
impériale encore pour les 6/10